a privilege of mine to introduce Sir
Michael Marmot is unquestionably
the world's leading experts the
socio-economic gradients and health and
the social determinants of those
inequities there's also one of the most
compelling and effective advocates for
changing the circumstances that lead to
those inequities I first became familiar
with marmots research when I learned if
some of his publications about Japanese
Americans and cardiovascular disease
that have been observed that Japanese
Americans had cardiovascular disease
rates that were lower than Japanese in
Japan and those in Hawaii had
intermediate rates and he did some
fascinating landmark studies that
demonstrated the link between
acculturation and cardiovascular disease
rates he went on to do many more
extremely important landmark studies one
of the most well known is the Whitehall
study there have been almost innumerable
important findings from that but one of
the ways it changed our thinking was the
demonstration that inequities in health
we're not just between deprived and poor
individuals and affluent individuals but
Whitehall showed that even within
British civil servant employed
individuals there were important
gradients Sir Michael has numerous
leadership and honorific titles he leads
the English longitudinal study on Aging
he chairs the UK department of health
scientific reference group and tackling
health inequities he's a fellow the
Academy of Medical Sciences and an
honorary fellow of the British Academy
in 2000 he was knighted by the Queen for
services to epidemiology and
understanding health inequities Sir
Michael is a vice president of the
academia euro Pia and as a member of the
Institute of Medicine he was chair of
the Commission on social determinants of
health set up by the w-h-o he's when the
balls an Prize for epidemiology has
given the Varian oration in 2006 and
when the William B grand prize for
Health Services Research at the request
of the British government he conducted a
review of health inequities which
published its report fair society
healthy lives in February 2010 if you
travel around the world people don't use
that title they refer to it as the mark
rapport he's now been invited by the
Regional Director of w-h-o to conduct a
European review of health inequities one
of the more fascinating developments I
think in Michaels career is that he
currently is president of the British
Medical Association I think it's
fascinating because someone who has
spent a lot of his career challenging
conventional ideas about the
determinants of health is now one of
them
he's been embraced by the government by
professional societies and by people
throughout the world who now recognize
the importance what he's done and are
accepting his leadership to change those
circumstances please join me in
welcoming Sir Michael Marmot who will
present about fair society healthy lives
it's an absolute pleasure to be here I
won't detain you for long by telling you
how much I'm sad to miss the Royal
Wedding actually a double pleasure to be
here as Paul said you've heard dazzling
science this morning what I've been
trying to do in the last little while is
use the best scientific evidence we can
gather not just to understand the world
but to change it one of the arguments
I'd be making and as I go along I'll
show you the evidence on social
determinants of health is that health is
a good measure of how we're doing as a
society there's a lot of interest now in
well-being I would say health is a
better measure of well-being than
well-being is and particularly the
distribution of health across society
health inequities I your successor as
director of NIH told me that you never
used the term inequality but the rather
bland term
despairities we use a rather more
muscular inequalities to say what we're
talking about but as Paul said there's
the issue of the social gradient let me
show you because Whitehall changed my
life it's not many people can say that
about the British civil service and in
case you're doubtful that insights from
studying British civil servants could
lead to my involvement in global health
I'll try and convince you of that if
you're not convinced by the time I
finish then you can send me back to
watch the Royal Wedding so these are
data from the first Whitehall study and
men in the second Whitehall study we
studied women as well as men
but men are classified by their
employment grade now these are people
permanently employed in the British
civil service we exclude the richest
people in society and we exclude the
poorest people in society and what you
see the drama of this is not just the
higher mortality and the people at the
bottom compared with the top but it's
the gradient people near the top have
higher mortality than those at the top
in the Marmot review in the review of
inequalities that we did in England we
plotted life expectancy by neighborhood
income deprivation so each of these dots
represents a small area of England
classified by level of income and the
top graph is life expectancy what you
can see is people near the top have
shorter life expectancy than those at
the top those in the middle have shorter
life expectancy than those near the top
and it goes all the way down in fact if
you're concerned with inequalities in
health
you should not be concerned only with
the poor health of the poor important as
that is and the implications are really
quite profound both for understanding
and for policy it's the problem is the
poor health of the poor then we should
study the poor and it's not totally
fanciful to understand why living in
absolute poverty could lead to poor
health but here we've got the social
gradient right across the whole of
society in the implications are not just
to reduce poverty but to change society
the bottom graph is disability free life
expectancy you can see a steeper
gradient for life expectancy the gap on
average between the 95th cental and the
5th sent out was seven years for
disability free life expectancy it's 17
years now it's been put to me that
nobody will be concerned about health
inequalities unless we can convince
governments that it makes economic sense
to take action my argument has been that
we should take action for moral reasons
avoidable health inequalities avoidable
health inequalities are wrong putting
them right is a matter of social justice
now suppose I tried to make the economic
case look at the difference between life
expectancy and disability free life
expectancy at the top people spend about
12 years of their lives with disability
at the bottom 20 years I've got a really
cost-effective measure for reducing that
handout free cigarettes to the poor
if you don't look very excited by that
of course you're not excited by that
it's corrupt it's morally wrong we don't
do things just because they're efficient
and cost-effective we do what's right
and you know that that's why you're not
interested in handing out free
cigarettes to the poor even though it's
cost effective and efficient because
it's the wrong thing to do
now suppose I were to try and take an
economic argument this green line
represents government policy the
previous government in Britain had a
policy of advancing working age to 68 by
2046 the current coalition government
was to do that more quickly were
retirement age today at 68
three-quarters of the population do not
have disability free life expectancy as
long as 68 government policy will run
into the buffers if we don't take action
on the social gradient the hold of
society in disability free life
expectancy and you see it in the u.s.
can't resist showing you this we did a
comparison from the English longitudinal
study of aging and the health and
retirement study looking at seven common
diseases show you three here the social
gradient by income both in England and
the US and for these seven common
diseases Americans were sicker than the
English a journalist in England said he
now uses this as a case study at how
good news gets little reported of bad
news gets greatly reported this ran and
ran in the u.s. that the Americans had
lost the health wars to the British but
it got a brief mention in the British
press but in both cases you see
particularly for diabetes and heart
disease the social gradient
it's been put to me by colleagues
working in low-income countries that the
social gradient is an effete concern of
rich countries he said in sub-saharan
Africa for example we're concerned with
the poorest of the poor and as I'll show
you in a moment that's not an adequate
description of what's going on
it relates in part to the question of
well what's more important absolute or
relative deprivation a march SN Nobel
laureate in economics said that relative
deprivation in the space of incomes in
the income dimension can you yield
absolute deprivation in the space of
capabilities translating that into
English prose what it's saying is it's
not just what you have but what you can
do with what you have and that's key
both to the understanding of the social
gradient of Health and the policy
implications when we look beyond the
rich countries we see this sort of
phenomenon life expectancy for men in
Sierra Leone is under 40 in Iceland it's
80 for women life expectancy in Zimbabwe
and Afghanistan is 42 in Japan it's 86
and there's no good biological reason
why we should be looking at a spread in
life expectancy of more than 40 years
when we published the reporter of the
w-h-o Commission on social determinants
of health I highlighted the Scottish
city of Glasgow in the poorest part of
Glasgow life expectancy for men is 54
and in the richest part it's 82 a
28-year difference in life expectancy in
one Scottish city life expectancy for
men in the poorest part of Glasgow is 8
years shorter than the average in India
in India three-quarters of the
population live on $2 a day or less no
one in Glasgow lives on $2 a day or less
in Glasgow they don't die of malaria
they don't die of communicable diseases
you turn on the tap the for sir the
water is safe to drink the food safe
well doesn't kill you in the short term
they die of heart disease and cancer and
violent deaths and other alcohol
associated deaths and so powerful of the
social determinants of health that life
expectancy for the poorest man in
Glasgow is eight years shorter than the
average in India and you have similar
differences in the United States and the
gradient is not an effete concern of
people working in rich countries when
that was put to me I said to this
colleague working in Uganda looking
under five mortality for the middle
wealth quintile at a hundred and sixty
four thousand live births if you had a
population with an under-five mortality
of 164 thousand live births wouldn't you
think that was worth taking action
that's the middle quintile in Uganda
which is higher than the bottom quintile
in India and you see in country after
country it's a social gradient we should
be trying to get everybody up to
the level of the best and indeed we
should be trying to get the best to a
better level and as I said at the
beginning the social gradient implies
that we have to take action across the
whole of society and it was that in mind
that the then director general of WH o
JW Lee set up the Commission on social
determinants of health and invited me to
chair it we launched the Commission in
Santiago de Chile in 2005 president
Lagos of Chile hosted the launch and he
then became a member of the Commission
JW Lee JW Lee said the goals not an
academic exercise actually I think
academic exercises are good things have
people spent my life in the university
but he said it's not an academic
exercise but to marshal scientific
evidences a lever for policy change we
published our report in 2008 and called
it closing the gap in a generation
closing the gap in a generation I've
just shown you that there's larger than
40 year gap in life expectancy across
the world and we called our report
closing the gap in a generation it was a
statement that we had the means it was a
statement that we have the knowledge to
close the gap in a generation the
question is do we have the political
will to do it
and doing it as I've said is a matter of
social justice and we put at the center
of what we were trying to achieve
empowerment of individuals of
communities indeed of whole countries
and we saw empowerment as having a
material dimension having enough money
to live on psychosocial
having control over your life not
suffering from the sort of chronic
stress that Elizabeth Blackburn was just
showing us and political having voice we
had three principles of action the
conditions in which people are born grow
live work and age the structural drivers
of those conditions a global national
and local level and the importance of
monitoring training and research and in
the conditions of daily life we had
recommendations on each of these and in
the structural drivers health equity in
all policies good global governance
gender equity political empowerment
market responsibility and fair financing
I was in Norway presenting our report
and the Minister of Foreign Affairs in
Norway said I am a health minister every
minister is a health minister and I
would say that every sector is a health
sector what happens in education and
environment and in finance all affect
health this is not as present as the BMA
the doctors trying to take over as usual
by the way nobody was more surprised
than I when I got a phone call saying
would you like to be President of the
British Medical Association I said you
know who you're talking to this is
Michael nama yeah yeah yeah I said you
know what I do they said yeah we know
you what'd you do I said I'm not going
to stop talking about health
inequalities just because I'm president
of the British Medical Association they
said no that would be fine we like you
not to get too political we expect the
President to be above the fray I'll say
a word about that in a moment
but but nevertheless although I think
what happens in the health sector is
important what happens outside the
health sector is
vital importance and we said in the
final report of the commission that
health inequity results from a toxic
combination of poor social policies and
programs unfair economic arrangements
and bad politics
I thought we shouldn't come on too
strong in investing pull our punches a
little bit the question is what would
government's make of this robust
language I never thought I would get to
the stage in my life where I thought
what happened at a World Health Assembly
was important but there we are
it happens and at the May 2009 World
Health Assembly in Geneva 39 government
representatives spoke glowingly about
the commission's report accepted the
general recommendations one of the
recommendations we made was that there
should be a global summit on health
inequalities and and social determinants
of health where all governments be asked
to report what they've been doing Brazil
came forward and said we'll host it and
it there will be a Rio summit in October
this year and I was thinking good
heavens one Sunday night I wrote down
this recommendation in global and now
it's happening they hoping to have 120
governments represented in Rio in
October this year the current
director-general Margaret Chan either
she or her speechwriter took the view
that public health can be grateful for
backing from the Commission on social
determinants of health one of the issues
with the global Commission is that we
were making recommendations for the
whole world sub-saharan Africa and
Glasgow are rather different Latin
America and North America and the
question is how to take this forward
well we tried to make a virtue of
necessity we said it was important for
governments to take this
on and to see how they could translate
the findings into the country context
Brazil set up its own Commission on
social determinants of health as
president Lula holding the report of the
Brazilian Commission there's a tinge of
sadness I would say but that's because
Brazil didn't win the World Cup I
presented a copy of our report to the
Indian Prime Minister Manmohan Singh dr.
Singh asked what would you like me to do
I thought he's the Prime Minister of 1
point 1 billion people and he's asking
me what he should do I said with respect
that life expectancy in India for women
had improved by 13 years in only 30
years it was now 63 it was 23 years
shorter than in Japan and there was no
reason why it shouldn't be the same as
in Japan well he minded to take the
recommendations of the Commission and
set up a process to see how it could be
applied in India I ventured to suggest
that there would be benefit around sri
lanka president accepted the report then
said about killing Tamils which wasn't
quite what we had in mind but they've
expressed some enthusiasm the new
president Costa Rica said that she would
make it a priority for her presidency so
there's been some acceptance from
different governments around the world
that they really want to do this and it
started I have to say with Whitehall
with the social gradient in British
civil servants and the British
government invited me to conduct a
review of health inequalities in England
and we published our report and I called
it fair society healthy lives and this
gets to the non-political nature of my
position as president the being
I was making a speech to the world
Medical Association and I said I was
rather regretful that we'd used the
title fair society healthy lives because
the coalition government in Britain
labels everything they do is fair they
raise value-added tax which is
regressive and they call it fair they
cut benefits to the poor and they call
it fair
they let the bankers get away with blue
murder and they call it fair I said it's
a grotesque parody of fairness next week
headlines in the British Medical Journal
News section president of the BMA labels
government policy as grotesque parody of
fairness the chairman of Council said
ruefully I guess you could call them a
political so I want to tell you a little
bit about the English review and I'd
venture to suggest that much of what we
did and concluded and recommended in
England would indeed have resonance in
the United States let me start with the
fact that context matters this is a
graph showing the share of total
household income firstly enjoyed by the
top 20% of earners so 1977 the top 20%
had about 36% of total household income
we then climbed this steep cliff so it
went up to about 40 to 43 percent that
was Margaret Thatcher was elected Prime
Minister Thatcher major Tony Blair
Gordon Brown didn't make any difference
once we got to the top of that cliff the
share of total household income enjoyed
by the top 20% stayed up there this is
the share of total household income for
the bottom 20% started off at about 9%
and went down to around 6% and stayed
there now that's bad enough the dotted
line is post-tax
doesn't make any difference at all I
thought what do I know I'm a doctor I
don't hurt clever stuff like economics I
thought we had a progressive taxation
system we don't we have a proportionate
taxation system I think if you put
fairness at the heart of all
decision-making you wouldn't do that you
certainly wouldn't do that in the United
States this is the household income
level at 2005 inflation adjusted dollars
the 95th Center and down here we have
that the 10th the 20th the 50th Center
essentially had no change in income the
median but this is what happened up at
the 90th and the 95th percentile if you
break that down and go for a longer
period of time this is the top 1%
something interesting happened in 1929 I
can't quite remember what it was but in
1929 the top 1% had about 24% of total
household income it would then went down
to about 8% look what happened in 2007
what interesting thing happened after
2007 when the top 1% went up to about
23% of total household income who
benefited from that who benefited from
there
is that putting fairness at the heart of
all decision-making and it has an impact
on the next generation
this shows international comparisons of
income mobility the problem with large
income inequality is the larger the gap
between the rungs of the ladder the more
difficult it is to climb that ladder so
what this graph shows is the comparison
of income of adult children with their
parents if you scored one there's
complete correspondence with the income
of offspring and the income of parents
if you score zero there's no relation
there's the US and there's the UK you
may think in the land of the Royal
Wedding that we've got more crystallized
social structures than you do sorry I'm
sorry
well the royal weddings only been
cooking for about seven years you've
been planning this event for two hundred
years yeah you have less income mobility
than any other rich country Italy France
Australia Norway Sweden Germany Canada
Finland and Denmark so it's having big
impact on the next generation the myth
is of course that any mother's son can
be President the fact is the reality is
that with big income inequalities
there's much less social mobility who
your parents are matters much more in
the United States than it does in Italy
France Australia Norway Sweden etc in
the English review we had six levels of
recommendations based on the best
science we could find and I'll go
through some of them just briefly the
first was give every child the best
start in life these data come from the
1970 British
birth cohort study and the look at
cognitive development at age 22 months
followed to ten years of age and these
are relative scores look first at the
children who are 22 months ranked in the
tenth Center if they grew up in families
self low socioeconomic status they
remain low there's some regression to
the mean but that need not detain us if
they grow up in families of high
socioeconomic status they catch up look
at the children who are in the 90th
Center at 22 months if they grew up in
families of high socioeconomic status
they remain high families of low
socioeconomic status they decline so if
you're poor and clever doesn't help you
much by the time you're 10 it wouldn't
have mattered much if you're rich and
dumb you still get up there
this is now known by political
commentators in Britain as that graph
assume for the moment that all the
differences that 22 months were
biologically determined jeans birth
trauma and that the differences
associated with family of rearing was
social the social Trump's the biological
in fact not all the differences at 22
months are biological the quality of
rearing in the first 22 months of life
makes a huge difference but it shows how
profound early life can be now why am i
showing you this
we're talking about health because early
child development determines what
happens when children get into the
school system that in turn determines
what happens in terms of employment and
income and where you live and that in
turn influence it may influence telomere
length and telomerase activity and it
certainly influences health gaps in
school readiness at age three and five
it's a gradient school readiness of
three by income quintiles are you
getting the message about the gradient
it's not just about the very poorest and
conduct problems goes the other way can
we do anything about this data from
Canada suggests half the deficit in
readiness for school associated with low
income can be reversed by reading to
children every day this is the social
gradient in reading to children every
day it was put to me that we were
reporting into an adverse economic
climate here's a really expensive
intervention read your children daily I
was presenting these data to one region
in England with a mix of chief executive
from local government and chief
executives from primary care trusts and
one chief executive from local
government led to her feet and said we
should implement this this afternoon
what are we waiting for regular bedtimes
at age three is one measure of
consistency of parent parenting and
mother suffered postnatal depression
with catastrophic effects on the
development of the children and it
follows the social gradient the other
way skip over education create fair
employment and good work for all this is
the percent of 16 to 18 year olds not in
education training and employment which
is absolutely vital in this economic
downturn the effect of unemployment is
selectively impacted on younger people
sixteen to seventeen year olds 37.7%
unemployed at the British Medical
Association I debated with our senior
health minister the Secretary of State
for health and I said to him this is a
public health measure active labor
market policies are vital for the public
health as we were doing the English
review we fought and formed partnerships
with various parts of England one of
which was in Liverpool deprived part of
the Northwest and they said to us in the
recession of the 1980s young people
leaving school who didn't get into work
never got into work and spent a lifetime
in unemployment and now we're looking at
second generation children facing the
same future and when we look at quality
of work in Whitehall - we've been
looking for example at job control high
grade low grade the higher the grade the
higher the level of control in the job
and we've shown I won't go into the data
now that I can
is associated with lower risk of
coronary heart disease lower risk of
mental illness lower risk of absence
from work this was a really radical
recommendation in a rich society ensure
that everybody has the minimum the
minimum income necessary for a healthy
life we said you can calculate how much
you need to have a healthy life it's
more than food clothes and shelter but
sufficient resources to support / to
participate in society and maintain
human dignity we said that if a
pensioner an old-age pensioner does not
have sufficient money to buy presents
for her grandchildren she doesn't have
the minimum income for necessary
necessary for a healthy life she can't
live a life of dignity and we said you
can do that calculation the minimum wage
and for people on benefits should be set
with regard to the minimum necessary for
a healthy life create and develop
healthy and sustainable places and
communities let me show you just one
example of some of the research on this
people are classified here in two ways
by income group and by exposure to green
space and looking at deaths from
circulatory disease so look first at the
group that had the least exposure to
green space the relative mortality from
circulatory disease in each group has
taken as one the second income group had
a relative mortality of about 1.3 the
third income group 1.7 and the bottom
income group about 2.2 now look at the
group with the middle level of exposure
to green space again you see the social
gradient but it's shallower now look at
the group with the most access to green
space and the gradient is shallower
still now of course higher income people
more access to green space but give the
population more access to green space
and you reduce the social gradient in
death from coronary heart disease we put
in our report figures that the amount of
money that have been spent on road
improvement over a four year period
had it been spent differently could have
led to 1,000 new urban parks - in every
local area with beneficial effects on
physical and mental illness and
strengthened the role in impact of ill
health prevention currently only 4% of
the National Health Service funding is
spent on prevention we said in our
report that should go up to 7% I said to
my colleagues after it's where did we
get 7% from how the hell did we get to
7% nobody could remember where we got to
but it's I guess it sounds more
scientific than doubling it you know so
we said 7% anyway it should be more than
it is and this should be partnership
working I've been thinking a little bit
about the social justice question the
most prominent philosopher from that
other New England University John Rawls
who's no one can think about social
justice without thinking of rules
justices fairness and rules difference
principle says that anything that
improves the lot of the worst off is
fairer than the alternate situation
so I've stylized this social position
mortality rate high social position low
and there's the social gradient now
imagine we improve things and so the
mortality went down for all groups
but it went down more for the top groups
in fact the higher you were to begin
with the greater benefit you got
in fact that's what's happened in the UK
and the United States over time health
has got better for everybody but the
gradients got steeper now under a rolls
Ian formulation the blue is fairer than
the red because things got better for
the worst off I've argued with
economists scratching economists you
find a utilitarian they say all
economists would agree that the blue is
better than the red because everybody is
better off I guess that's true but to
call it fairer when we've got steeper
inequalities seems to me perverse it's
better if everybody is better off and
that suggests to me that we have to have
two major goals one is to improve health
for everybody the blue is an advance on
the red but the second major goal is to
make it fairer to reduce inequalities in
health so we've made progress on the one
but not on the other and we've got to do
both and health inequalities are not
inevitable or immutable look at two
regions of England the Northeast and the
southwest by a socio-economic
classification this is mortality for the
top group the doctors and lawyers and
then going down the social gradient the
lower you are in the social gradient the
more it matters where you live the
gradient is steeper in the Northeast
than it is in the southwest if we can
have that much difference in the
gradient at one point in one country
then surely we ought to be trying to get
the gradient and the Northeast to
represent that in the southwest it ought
in principle to be possible
imagine send who I've quoted consistent
with what I've been saying about
empowerment says the success of an
economy and of the society cannot be
separated from the lives that the
members of the society are able to lead
we not only value living well and
satisfactorily but also appreciate
having control over our lives let me
finish with Glasgow where I started
Glasgow Liverpool and Manchester are all
in a sense post-industrial cities if you
want to understand what I mean go and
visit Cleveland and you get the picture
these are all post-industrial cities
hollowed out and they have rather
similar levels of income inequality but
Glasgow has higher mortality than
Liverpool and Manchester look at the
causes of death that show the biggest
relative excess in Glasgow compared to
Liverpool and Manchester drug-related
poisoning alcohol-related deaths suicide
and external causes and then lung cancer
which is behavioural it's smoking but
these four they are all chronic stress
they're all psychosocial a major element
of the excess risk of premature death
seen in Scotland is psycho socially
determined and Harry burns the chief
medical office of the Scotland says
points to study evidence of low sense of
control self self efficacy and self
esteem in populations in these areas
colleagues at a university like this one
with a distinguished tradition and a
medical school as I've heard I think
three times in the last 12 hours with
the highest NIH income per faculty
member of
University in the United States so with
a deservedly proud tradition we have to
think about how we can use science and
the best interest of promoting the
health of populations and reducing
inequalities in health and I come back
to why we called English review fair
society healthy lives
put fairness at the heart of all
decision making and health will improve
and health inequalities will diminish I
think what we're trying to achieve is
conditions in which individuals and
communities have control over their
lives and participate fully in society